bonjour je m'appelle michael abélard
je catégorise plutôt je participe au
challenge des créateurs dans la
catégorie innovation donc avec la
société il ya this on intervient dans le
domaine de la valorisation de
l'information depuis deux ans maintenant
la société a été créée en 2012 donc
valorisation de l'information qu'est ce
que ça veut dire c'est à dire qu'on
intervient en fait sur la triptyque de
la gestion de la donnée c'est à dire sa
sélection sa mise en forme en terme de
de reporting par le biais de solutions
logicielles ou d'accompagnement la
protection des données à caractère
personnel avec la mise en conformité
cnil et la formation des équipes bonjour
je m'appelle boyer audrey j'ai 27 ans et
j'ai décidé de participer au concours
challenge et créateurs dans la catégorie
innovation
alors on a décidé de lancer une marque
de prêt-à-porter masculin et féminin à
la réunion on dessine en amont les
modèles ensuite on les fait fabriquer à
l'étranger pour les revendre ici à la
ring donc en termes de distribution la
marque est distribuée dans le nord et
dans le sud de l'île qui nous permet
d'augmenter un petit peu la visibilité
de la marque et en termes de
communication des présentes sur tous les
réseaux sociaux qu'on fabrique des
tuniques pour femmes famille prix nets
unique pour femmes des robes ou des
t-shirts des sweats et également des
casquettes pour donc voilà donc ce qui
fait l'originalité de la marque c'est
vraiment en termes de création pour en
termes de motifs recherché motifs
dessinés et son côté épuré
j'ai un bac + 5 marketing marketing
études de marché commercialisation et
j'étais également demandeur d'emploi
donc et je suis aussi passionné de mode
donc j'ai décidé d'allier on va dire
compétences et ben passion donc voilà
donc on s'est lancé dans une création
d'entreprise autour du prêt-à-porter
ça n'a pas été si compliqué ça puisqu'on
a été accompagnée par la chambre des
métiers et la boutique de gestion donc
on a eu vraiment un excellent
accompagnement là dessus et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui nous suivent maintenant
appris de matricule à sion mais c'est
vrai que c'est un combat tous les jours
et c'est un véritable défi
bonjour je suis monsieur biotteau david
jeu concours dans la catégorie de la
réinsertion professionnelle
je suis ancien militaire de carrière et
j'ai entamé une reconversion à l'âge de
40 ans comme plombier chauffagiste et
j'ai ouvert mon entreprise de plomberie
sur saint-louis le 1er janvier 2012 et
donc je suis spécialisé dans tout ce qui
est dépannage sanitaires et plomberie de
saint-joseph jusqu'à jusqu'au port 7
jours sur 7 24 heures sur 24